well we're all hoping and praying that
the Prime Minister makes the speediest
possible recovery we know that the
Primus was taken into intensive care
last night at 7 o'clock number 10
released a statement at 8 and the prongs
was getting the best possible care from
the superb team of doctors at ATS and
Thomas's and of course they'll be
updates from number 10 throughout the
day well all of us recognize that the
corona virus is a new disease and
therefore it would be wrong for me to to
second-guess the the expert treatment
that the Prime Minister is being given
at some thomas's we just all hope that
he makes the speediest possible recovery
and in the interim the work abutment is
on the promise has given us clear
instructions about what he wants us to
do in order to make sure that we
maintain social distancing guidelines
slow the spread of this terrible disease
and then build up the resilience of the
NHS in order to make sure that as many
people as possible can be given the care
they need at the time they need
well the clinicians gave us the
information last night about the
deterioration and the prime is just
condition and they're working hard now
in order to make sure that Prime
Minister is amazing as possible position
but I'm not going to second-guess their
judgement
I think it's vitally important that we
allow those people who are looking after
the Prime Minister to get on with the
job they're the people who have the
skill the the expertise the compassion
on the front line and I know that
Chronister is in good hands and our
thoughts and prayers are with him at
this point yes the pointers outlined to
Dominic the importance of following the
plan that has been agreed and Dominic
will be chairing that meeting the
morning meeting that occurs at 9:15 and
which will be infringing with minors as
byrne looking at the nature of the
spread of the disease looking at the the
way which the measures the occlusion
place have been working and then
considering what more we can do in order
to make sure that the NHS is
strengthened looking at the the various
different treatments and the various
different
approaches that can be taken in order to
make sure that we're in a best position
than before to look after and care for
people
well the know naturally the Prime
Minister is having the best care
possible I know that he wants the
government to carry on working
effectively were fortunate that we've
got a great team of civil servants and a
strong team of across government working
as one doing everything we can to
implement the Prime Minister now moving
on could you tell us what your role is
going to be in the absence of Boris
Johnson Thank You Adam I'm part of the
team working to Dominic robb
Dominic chairs the meeting which is
coming up in just a few minutes time
which brings together the chief medical
officer the chief scientific advisor
various ministers and also key civil
servants we look at the progress of
disease consider what's what more is
needed in order to strengthen me NHS and
then there are different ministerial
groups that meet during the day and
there's one that looks that the the NHS
specifically which match hand called
chairs and one that looks at how the
economy and business can be kept
resilient through this difficult time
and that's chaired by Ritchie sooner the
Chancellor with Outlook trauma the
business secretary is his deputy yes and
of course all of us wish mr. Johnson a
speedy recovery but there has been some
concern expressed that with him not able
to provide a leadership role at the
moment it will be difficult to develop
an exit strategy or to have a meaningful
three week report on the lockdown next
week
how is that going to be taken forward
well it is the case that will that we
will review the progress of the disease
and do the nature of the lockdown
collectively as a cabinet the cabinet
will be chaired by Dominic Robb the
Foreign Secretary as the first secretary
of state and will review the the
evidence that we have in front of us and
then will take an appropriate decision
but you know as
you appreciate Adam as we all appreciate
nobody likes a lockdown that none of us
wanted but the fact that the Prime
Minister and others are in a serious
condition as a result of this disease
emphasizes the importance of making sure
that we all do everything we can to
limit the spread of the disease some
governments are now setting up active
exit committees if you like on a workout
how they're going to take their
countries out of lockdown the Austrians
have done so the Germans are talking
about it and we at that stage do we have
any senior minister in charge of the
exit strategy the next stage well we are
looking collectively and that's one of
the purposes of the 9:15 meeting at
exactly what the nature and the scale
and the spread of the diseases but any
decision will ultimately be taken by
cabinet collectively well you expect
that to be taken before the update to
the nation next week on the on the
three-week lockdown well we were looking
at the information there will be an
update next week and the cabinet will
discuss the situation in the next few
days before everyone was shocked and
taken by surprised by the news that the
Prime Minister has been taken into
intensive care last night particularly
since I've been a news conference only a
few hours before was the government
leveling with the nation at those
briefings telling them what the
situation was and and was it as taken by
surprise yes we were the the briefing
that was given at 5:00 o'clock I was
given at a time when we didn't know
about the deterioration and the Prime
Minister's condition we were informed
subsequently the promise that was
admitted to intensive care at 7 o'clock
and that information wasn't given to to
us in government to those in the cabinet
until just before 8 o'clock
given his importance to the nation do
you think with hindsight he could have
been looked after better
well I think the Prime Minister followed
medical advice and he was at all times
operating with a stripped back diary and
following the the guidance that he was
being given by his his doctors and I
think now all of us just pray and hope
that the Prime Minister will recover
well